i am a huge
fan of steven soderbergh and i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
making
the making of a movie so for both of you
can you talk a little bit about
what might surprise people to learn
about the making of a soda berg movie
um i think people would find surprising
that he
um he holds the camera
he's the essentially the dp
and also edits um the film himself and
post i mean i'm not sure if he has
people that help him but he's really on
the editing floor
doing all the back end work that
most directors don't do so i think that
he's really like a
one-man army like a you know
he really knows how to do it all and um
yeah he's just incredible he and even on
set he just
you know he knows he knows what he's
looking for
he knows when he got it and then we can
move on
it's not a lot of repeating the same
thing over and over
you know and if something doesn't work
he has a new
strategy immediately you know he's he's
just so great
no oh no i i agree with that i'm very
intrigued with what's behind you
it's a distraction from it's a
distraction from
um this uh one of the things ray i'll
ask this of you
um for or for both of you um i i was a
big
i loved ed solomon's script for this and
i love the way it weaves in real history
with um these small time criminals can
you talk a little bit about what you
responded to with the script
what you're excited for people to see
well just the whole movie in general
you're
you're reading the script and you you
know you never know what's gonna happen
after you you know all of a sudden
someone turns left when you think
they're gonna go right
and it was just really interesting all
these characters but there was a duality
to to a lot of what was going on and
then greed
just gets more and more and more so by
the end of the movie
you see what the ultimate creed is is is
because it looked like you said it
what what it's true in terms of what
they were stealing and what the
situation was that the auto
uh uh industry didn't use when they
could have which would
infects everything probably even to go
back not to get goofy but
just climate change based on what would
be different if they didn't
do or or if they did what they were
gonna
that they should have done with what it
is that that everybody's looking for
to steal the thing that stood out to me
the most
and what i really sympathized a lot with
with my character was
just her place as a woman during that
time period
and how her worth and her value came
from
you know who she's married to and and
that's
pretty much it and you know there was a
glass ceiling for women
like you can excel but only in this
field or
you know and so i love and even in crime
there wasn't a big space for women so i
love that vanessa's kind of like you
know what
i'm just gonna do the most extreme thing
possible
and i'm gonna get what i want for once
and not just be like a pawn in this
game you know what arm candy for these
guys
um and i don't think we see it come i
didn't see it coming when i read the
script
and when she did that i was like yes
like she was just my hero
um so i yeah i i hope that
other people can sympathize with that as
well
i yes um uh before i run out of time
i'm incredibly excited for david chase's
uh the many saints of newark
um which i guess is finally coming out
soon uh
what can you tease about that film what
what are fans
what can fans expect well it's
really really good and because david
wrote it what it is it's a prequel
about the characters that that you know
from the the show the sopranos
in the movie here it's uh you find out
how it all started james gandolfini's
character which actually was played by
his real son
uh michael it's just really it's just
really good and
interesting how those characters he
wrote it really smart
and it's a movie into itself you don't
have to have seen all the soprano
shows to appreciate what happens here
because it
lives alone but but if you do know the
show
you see them growing and what happened
when they were young and how they got to
where they are on that note i have to
stop
i just want to say congrats on this
movie specifically and have a fantastic
day
thank you